Moe villains no problems so here we go
with me poking the bear talking about
the DC EU again and thinking about
something that nobody else seems to be
bringing up now there's all kind of a
curve to me I got thinking about it when
I stumbled across the umpteenth video
with some buddies think piece on what is
wrong with Marvel's villains and how
does that make them better and before I
even get started down this path yes
Marvel has classically had a problem
with its villains in the movies even
people who really like the MCU of which
I consider myself generally tend to
acknowledge most of the villains have
been forgettable bland uninteresting and
just overall not the highlight of the
movie and as a result plenty of people
have thrown out their thoughts on the
MCU villain problem but um guys DC's got
a villain problem - now it's a
distinctly different realm from the one
that Marvel has and has to do with the
way that two different companies have
approached making their superhero based
movies and how they're villains fit into
that now before I get into that too much
I think the reason that people haven't
thought of or haven't been talking about
the C's villain problem is because well
because of Heath Ledger's Joker people
think DC villains he immediately comes
to mind
the thing is though the Nolan Batman
films are not in continuity with the DC
EU you can give the DCE you credit for
that any more than the MCU can take
credit for what was done in the Raimi
spider-man movies different creative
people different regime different
continuity but like I said DC does have
a villain problem with its movies but it
is not the same problem that Marvel's
has Marvel's problem with villains is I
don't want to say it's deliberate but I
think it's knowing it's something that
they knew was going to happen because
Marvel very much made the deliberate
decision going into their films to put
the focus much more on the heroes to a
degree actually that hadn't really been
seen in these kinds of movies before
because usually you were getting at neo
a 50/50 split between hero and villain
but here Marvel really put a much
heavier
phasis on villains which resulted in
villains either being sidelined being in
the background not showing up for a lot
of the movie or not even getting
revealed until the very end in some
cases but again I think that was
delivered because they decided look we
got to make sure that people love these
heroes and because that's what we're
going to keep bringing over and over and
over and over again
whereas our villains and most of them
are going to die at the end of the movie
if they're not in love with the villain
not the end of the world
now just because they did it on purpose
doesn't mean it's still a problem it is
but I think it's one that they knew they
were setting up for themselves
DC's villain problem is almost the
opposite I think at a lot of ways they
were trying to chase down those highly
memorable villains of things like the
Tim Burton Batman and the Nolan movies
and to be fair it may have been
something that they were deliberately
trying to do that Marvel wasn't which
was to deliver powerful memorable
villains because honestly Marvel again
and I'm restricting this to the movies
I'm not talking about the Netflix I'm
not talking about the TV shows I'm not
talking about any of that I'm just
talking about the movies just to
streamline this conversation but Marvel
was not filling the villain niche and I
think Deezy thought they could do that
but let's look at the villains they've
actually given us so far
first Manor steel we had General Zod
probably the best villain that the DCU
had delivered so far and a big part of
that is Michael Shannon he is a good
powerful presence he delivered a
slightly over-the-top but a pretty
memorable performance and it worked he
was credible as a threat and he was a
pretty successful villain then we got
BBS first off we had lex luthor by jesse
eisenberg and just know and then
doomsday at the end of it who just was
had no personality who was a big hulking
monster he only showed up at the end
there wasn't a lot to him he was
functional as far as being a boss fight
but that's really all he was Suicide
Squad enchantress oh god that one that
one was painful I know some people might
bring up the Joker but first of all I
would argue that the Joker isn't really
a villain in the story because he's not
an obstacle to anything that's actually
going on in the plot he's a bad guy sure
but so are the heroes so that doesn't
automatically qualify them for villain
status even if we want to count him as a
villain knowing that you know this is a
bill and his character if he shows up
again hope
be the full-on bad guy of something but
even if we take that route and want to
label it as a villain tear little Joker
at best highly divisive credit to them
for trying they tried to do something
new with him but for the most part it
didn't really seem to take and then
there's Wonder Woman which is DC's most
successful film critically way up there
in terms of box office it has done
phenomenally but I would say that its
villain is one of its weaker aspects and
considered as a spoiler warning for
Wonder Woman because some of this stuff
is towards the end of the movie I am
going to have to talk about it now
interestingly Wonder Woman they DC took
almost a more Marvel excess Caprona the
hero and therefore the villain and by
that I mean when they were making a
particularly BVS but also Man of Steel
to certain extent they really seem to be
banking on built-in cultural awareness
of who these heroes were as a way to not
have to spend as much time really
zeroing in on them and to try and spend
more time with the villains or in the
case of Batman V Superman get away with
splitting the time between two heroes
even though it was our introduction to
one of them but they seem to be aware
that Wonder Woman didn't have while you
know most people know the name she
didn't have the same building
understanding of who she was her origin
ordeal and everything so they put a much
bigger focus on that making sure we got
to make sure audiences get her and love
her yes there'll be a villain he'll show
up at the end and we'll deal with that
then and like I said that's a bit more
Marvel ik now
let me be clear I don't believe it was
intentional that they were trying to eat
marvel's you know way of doing things
nor do I think the fact that it does
more closely resemble more will
automatically make it a better film
that's not what I'm saying but what I'm
saying is they understood that they had
to sell Wonder Woman much harder than
Ares because ultimately Ares in the big
scheme of things wasn't really going to
matter but what I said about how Warner
Brothers seems to have been banking on
pre-existing understanding especially in
terms of Batman and Superman I think
speaks to a lot of what they've been
trying to do with their villains and it
just hasn't been working up to that
point if you pull up a list of you know
any kind of list there's a ton of them
out there all like all-time great movie
villains you'll start to notice a couple
of recurring
patterns which is a lot of the ones that
are really high up in those lists tend
to either be villains that appear in
sequels or villains that appear
alongside heroes who fit a pretty
specific box and I'll explain that a
little deeper but what this means is is
that the heroes are something that the
audience already understand so not as
much time needs to be devoted for them
therefore we get a really kick butt
villain obviously in terms of sequels
this is automatic because the audience
has already seen this hero before they
don't need a complete refresher and
that's how you get things like really
great Bond villains I would argue that
was what puts Darth Vader over the top
because he was good in Star Wars but he
became great in Empire Strikes Back and
Loki as much as I love Loki he wasn't
really great until they brought him back
a second time and we got more time on
him and Avengers and also I want to be
clear what I think time I'm focused on
the build I'm not talking about raw
minutes I'm not talking about screen
time because one of the ones I want to
bring up is Hannibal Lecter who has very
little screen time in that movie but
hovers over the the signs of lambs the
entirety as a present so that's another
one I want to bring up because when you
deal with great villains that aren't
necessarily in sequels the other pattern
you tend to see are ones who are
opposite things like police or
detectives or something that is very
easily identified by the ADI
identifiable by the audience and that's
where you get people like Hannibal
Lecter or John Doe from seven or Hans
Gruber from die hard because the heroes
in those cases fit pretty clear
archetypes now that's not me saying that
those heroes are shallow or aren't good
characters they are but they're very
quickly understood John McClane in die
hard is a blue-collar cop a kind of a
rough-and-tumble guy we know what that
character is like so that gives us an
immediate base level of knowledge that
Bruce worth can then build on without
having to spend a ton of actual time
focusing on him which means we get to
focus more on Hans Gruber which means we
like him better great villain same with
clarice starling she is the rookie cop
again that is a basic fundamental trope
and we have a baseline understanding of
what that character is like Jodie Foster
is then able to give what nuance she has
without having to eat up a ton of the
focus of the film
to put more focus on hannibal lecter
great villain likewise john doe played
by Kevin Spacey in seven because we've
got our detectives we've got the guy
about to retire we've got the sort of
grizzled detective with the troubled
home again stuff we've seen over and
over again and enough that we can now
build these characters and get more time
focusing on our villain great villain
and I think the problem that we've
landed on is Warner Brothers in the DCE
you tried to jump ahead assuming that
they could do that just because we were
dealing with Batman and Superman and
Batman and Superman are very well known
characters but they don't have the same
based in level of understanding like
something like a cop does because as
long as the characters may have been
around they've only been in film in the
case of Superman since the late 70s and
in the case of Batman since 89 and even
those are kind of separate comic book
movie errors the modern era of comic
book movies start in the early 2000 so
we've gotten around about say 20 years
with sort of this current boom of
superhero movies that may sound like a
long time but think about it your
cultural understanding of what a
superhero is and what the tropes of the
superhero is is not as baked in as cops
who have been depicted in movies since
silent film so you've got a hundred
years of understanding what a cop in
movies usually is versus 20 years of
understanding what a superhero movies
usually is this is able to skip ahead a
lot more easily than this because
there's still this still a lot being
explored with superheroes they haven't
been on film consistently long enough
with enough variance for audiences to be
able to quickly immediately zero in on
exactly what type of hero we're talking
about whether we're talking about a
tortured hero an altruistic hero a hero
with a past a hero out for revenge
exactly what it is now over time as
we're getting as a pop culture a better
mass media understanding of these
characters so that it's not just the
comic book geeks who know how these
things work then we may be able to skip
some steps ahead the way things like
diehard asylums or lambs the Bond films
etc were able to do but how they were
there yet with superheroes and Warner
Brothers in DC banked on the idea that
they were and they could skip ahead they
could skip a Batman solo people know
Batman will just shove a bad will just
Chubb Ben Affleck in the suit and that
would be enough they'll zero in on him
right away
but they didn't people were going wait
it seems like he's killing people I
thought Batman doesn't kill and no I'm
not trying to get into that argument but
I'm just saying you see those scenes you
see guns on the thing and the most
immediate Batman we'd seen prior to that
was one who really made a huge deal of
fact that he didn't kill so you didn't
give audiences a chance to get
acclimated to this new Batman therefore
they're still trying to figure that out
while you're throwing in these villains
who are eating up screen time that
honestly should have been better devoted
to getting us to understand these heroes
and I think that is a big part of why
these villains haven't worked which is
that for a villain to work any villain
they need to be playing off of a good
solid hero and like I said DC up until
Wonder Woman had kind of been skipping
ahead the closest they came to really
building a superhero and making sure the
audience got who they were they were was
in Man of Steel which I would say is
part of the reason that Zod is probably
the best villain that we've gotten from
the DC EU so far now that's been their
problem so far is it going to continue
to be their problem going forward well I
hope not
that said the movies come out where we
know what the villain is there's some
more potential problems on the immediate
horizon we've got Justice League coming
up we're going to Steppenwolf there's an
immediate problem with Steppenwolf which
is that we know he's not the big boss
he's a mid-boss he works for Darkseid
and we're just dealing with middle
management it's the same fundamental
problem that Ronan the accuser had in
the first guardians of the galaxy rule
because we knew Santos was behind them
so I was like why do why are we dealing
with this guy I'm not going to say
that's going to be impossible to
overcome or you know if Justice League
chooses to put the focus much more on
the heroes and less on the villain it
may not matter as much but I don't
expect him to turn around this villain
issue the Aquaman movie we're going to
be getting ocean master and Black Manta
that might do it I don't know I can't
really speculate on that because I don't
think we have a good enough sense of how
Aquaman is even going to function as a
character much less how his villains are
going to function so depending on how
well Aquaman gets established in Justice
League and how much time additionaly
gets put on him in his own movie but who
knows could go either way the other one
where we know who the villain is or
was was the Shazam movie Dwayne Johnson
is Black Adam now this this could have
really been in this could have been
rebuilding turn for the DC EU this could
have been their Loki they're Darth Vader
they're whoever you want to put in their
big intimidating inherently charismatic
guy immediate physical threat you really
get a sense a presence for him and last
we heard he is not actually appearing in
the Shazam movie he is instead going to
be getting his own solo spin-off movie
completely separate and now we don't
even know who she's am is fighting so
all of this is recoverable but the first
thing that the DP you have to fix
ultimately is get their heroes in line
and again if you like the DC in you
that's great but with the reception that
Wonder Woman has had versus their other
films and got them the higher degree of
universal praise where they focus
greater on the hero and less on the
villains and potential threats that may
be showing the DC that before you can
leap ahead and try and give us an
ultimate iconic villain performance
you've got to be sure these characters
and these heroes work first I mean it
seems like an obvious point but there's
a reason that's the Joker within the
second Dark Knight movie not the first
one because the first one was all about
Bruce Wayne and scarecrow was a great
villain don't get me wrong but he's
nowhere near the villain that the Joker
was forget even the specific
performances Christopher Nolan knew not
to blow the great villain on that first
movie because the first movie had to be
about building up the hero and that's
the step that DC tried to skip but there
does seem to be a lot of realigning
rethinking how they're going to move
forward with their movies and I am like
I've said in a couple of recent videos
I'm much more hopeful for the future of
DC movies than I was for quite a while
now depending on how Justice League and
then Aquaman come out that that hope
could get squashed really quick and it
could just end up being a hope for
Wonder Woman as a solo franchise and not
for this universe as a whole
we'll see I don't really know if I have
an ultimate point in all this I could it
was it was just bothering me the fact
that there were so many think pieces in
our
: this and that and sort of a
universally accepted fact that Marvel
has a villain problem which they do and
I'm not denying that but there was no
acknowledgement that DC with its Khan
Cinematic Universe wasn't very much
better though for different reasons and
I just I don't know I just felt like I
needed to throw that out there do you
think I'm completely nuts if you could
tell me so without you know swearing at
me and wishing me bodily harm then go
ahead and drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]